November has come and gone for some of
you that means thanksgiving for others
it means colder weather and for the rest
of you it's just another month
jam-packed with headlines so to help you
remember the important stuff here are
the biggest news stories of November
number 10 watchdogs to multiplayer fail
watchdogs to is out and plenty of you
are having a blast hacking every tech
bros computer and cell phone across the
bay area but the game seamless
multiplayer wasn't quite up to snuff
sure you could actively invite friends
into your game for co-op but coming
across random players in the city would
cause major performance issues
thankfully it's now being brought back
online in phases kind of funny how a
game about messing with machines had
technical issues right number nine nes
classic shortages no i'm not talking
about the cable on the controller
although that thing's pretty short to
see the nes classic is a good deal 30
great nintendo games for sixty bucks in
fact it's such a good deal that it sold
out almost instantly some jerks were
even selling them on ebay for more than
200 bucks as of the time of this video
they're still hard to come by so
hopefully your kids will be happy with
the 3ds lineup this holiday number 8 the
canceled diddy kong racing sequel
speaking of nintendo games that are hard
to get our hands on here's another we'll
never get the chance to play diddy kong
racing adventure was meant to be a
gamecube sequel to the n64 classic a
sort of fusion of that game is racing
and more adventure game play ptop online
managed to dig up some test footage of
the game giving us a glimpse at what did
ii second out and could have looked like
well at least we can always use them in
smash brothers number seven Telltale's
guardians of the galaxy speaking of
adventures guardians of the galaxy is a
pretty great one and telltale games is
known for adapting stories like that for
its own episodic series seems like a
perfect match right according to a
report from Eurogamer that's exactly
what's happening it lines up with
guardians vol 2 is release date next
year as well so you might just be making
big decisions for star-lord Groot in the
whole crew in the near future number six
neck
from answers in diablo 3 for lots of you
November means blizzcon blizzards annual
gathering was jam-packed with fan
service including the beloved
necromancer class from diablo 2 and now
he's triumphantly rising from the grave
for the third game Blizzard calls him a
master of the dark arts and a badass in
general you'll be able to summon
skeletons and blood monsters when the
new class debuts in 2017 it should be
killer number 5 Pokemon stars on switch
we know that in 10 dose which is coming
next March but that just means we'll be
hearing a ton of rumors between then and
now Eurogamer has been right about a
bunch of these and the site said we
could be getting a third version of
Pokemon Sun and Moon codenamed Pokemon
stars now personally I think Pokemon
Eclipse sounds better but a full Pokemon
adventure on a console is nothing to
sneeze at fingers crossed for some
Pokemon Stadium style battles with all
the new monsters number for blizzards
first person shooter everyone loves
Blizzard games heck I've already
mentioned one of them in this video but
the studio is already at work on their
next big project and according to some
job listings it's going to be a first
person game right now the developers
only first person title is over watch
but considering how massive that games
become in less than a year you can't
blame the team for wanting to dip back
into the FPS well we'll have to see what
happens number 3 no man's skies giant
update look I'm not gonna lie I didn't
expect to be talking about no man's sky
in November but the team at hello games
finally broke their silence by
announcing the foundation update this
massive addition to the game will add
home bases farming tools campsites new
resources and even new game modes now
you'll be able to wander the galaxy for
fun build to survive or just create the
planet base of your dreams and the
studio says this is a foundation for
more things to come way to come back
with a bag guys number two sombras
arrival remember when I said everyone
loves Blizzard games well they also love
new content for those games after months
and I mean months of teases the newest
overwatch hero sombra was finally
revealed the new assault hero is a
hacker who can teleport hack
hours and even turn invisible and if you
log into overwatch right now you'll
probably see at least four of them on
the other team well I guess you couldn't
see them if they're all invisible but
you get the point sombra is really cool
number one so much mass effect news Mass
Effect Andromeda is on the horizon pun
totally intended and thanks to a Game
Informer cover story we've got more than
enough info to keep us happy now we know
that it takes place 600 years after the
second game has loyalty missions you can
take on before or after the climax has
no loading screens between ship and
planets and has multiplayer that ties in
with the main story and that's all
before we even see the game in action at
the game awards seriously Mass Effect
Andromeda is shaping up to be out of
this world pun totally intended again
and those are the stories will remember
from November if there's anything we
missed feel free to leave a comment
below and if you're watching on YouTube
why not hit that subscribe button for
more great stuff gamespot has news
previews reviews and more around the
clock so for all the important video
game stuff you need to know you're
already in the right place
[Music]